all right Raymond Biden let a
Thanksgiving Day tradition that White
House turkey pardon even if he managed
to kind of botch
it this is the 76th anniversary of this
event and I want you to know I wasn't
there in the first
one I was too young to make it
up now Laura he's wrong on both counts
here he's 81 which is more than 76 but
the turkey paron as anybody who read my
book The Magnificent Mischief of Tad
Lincoln knows that was instituted 1863
by Tad and Abraham Lincoln by the way
Laura I just interviewed the two turkeys
Biden pardon today for Fox and Friends
the full interview is coming
Thanksgiving morning but here's a little
exclusive Ingram angle preview what are
your most concern the president might
ask
you well he's showing us now how to exit
this is good what are you most concerned
about the president requesting of
you come on he's not going to ask you to
Pardon him he's not up for anything he's
fine the nice thing is you're going to
end up in a nice farm and not on a table
this is a good thing for
you Laura we bring you up close and
personal to the newsmakers I mean we
really tried to strain to do
that well that I of course I'm thinking
that beautiful bed that beautiful bed at
the Willard Hotel is with that turkey
that's those are beautiful sheets and
beautiful Lin I mean what happened with
those that's what I'm thinking about
well they have they have pads on that
bed for obvious reasons I have to say
they were a little smelly uh but this
this tradition it's actually a beautiful
White House tradition and a monument to
Abraham and Tad Lincoln and the the idea
of mercy and forgiveness that Lincoln
extended to so many after the Civil War
to bring the country together but uh I
don't know I think it's lost on the
president he did man manage to Pardon
these turkeys Liberty and Bell but
you'll have to Pardon his setup
listen now just to get here Liberty and
Bell had to beat some tough odds in
competition they had to work hard to
show patience and be willing to travel
over a thousand miles you could say even
this harder than getting a a ticket to
the Renaissance tour or or
or ritage tour she's down in it's kind
of warm in Brazil right now
Laura he meant Taylor Swift Britney
Spears hasn't even performed in years
but another singer cardi B is sounding
off on Biden and she's not pardoning
him there's a 120 million budget cut in
New York that is going to affect schools
public libraries and um the police
department and a $5 million budget cut
in sanitation we're going to be drowning
rats yeah Joe Biden is talking about
about like yeah we could fund two Wars
like we're the greatest nation no we're
not we're going through some right now
we're going to be drowning and rats rats
and squirrels and
racco Laura it's kind of funny listening
to her what she's talking about is the
migrant crisis in New York City cardi B
by the way like so many others uh The
Rock and and so many other celebrities
they supported Biden in 2020 now they
have buyers remorse she apparently
doesn't like it like
that well Raymond Raymond first of all I
love the fact that she's going totally
cash I like the fact that she's very
comfortable with her audience so she's
with her bathrobe and you know I'm not
sure if is that a shower cap I don't
know what that but I like that I mean
she's just really natural she's not all
glammed up she's just like I'm the end
of the day and I'm gonna speak my mind
yeah I'm GNA speak my mind
30 minutes well you know yes 30 minutes
I think look people are clearly being
affected by this and not just the
working class or the middle class these
are people on the upper astons of
entertainment and society and they're
feeling it these are people who
supported Joe Biden so what you're
seeing here is far beyond Politics the
cultural power of cardi B The Rock and
others Kevin Hart calling out the
president in specific ways this may have
political consequences no one sees right
no well let me tell you let me tell you
this I think that cardi B needs to go to
Chicago in the south side of Chicago she
needs to go to in in La she needs to she
needs to go all these places and she
needs to preach the gospel about what's
really happened to the country so not
just on Instagram she needs to preach
the gospel to to Urban America and do do
it more she's using her platform right
you're all over the holiday I know your
Christmas Mary and bright Al is a number
one Jazz release on Amazon wow
congratulations where you going on the
road thank you I am going starting this
weekend Laura in Phoenix on November
25th I'm going to be there then Dallas
with Jose Feliciano Tampa Cleveland with
Frankie Avalon finally Raymond at the
Ryman Auditorium in Nashville on
December 25th go for1st go to Raymond
Royal christmas.com for tickets cannot
wait to see you all in the
road I have a lot of friends who are
going to the Nashville event in Ryman
Raymond thanks Jess hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else